you know I I listen like I listen to the
to the the
poking and people saying like what what
is going on like how does he try to
connect how does he able to connect
these things together I've been thinking
a lot about the idea of transpersonal
agency in terms of
again trying to bridge the traditional
categories like the angiology of the
ancient world and the even just the
hierarchy of gods or the hierarchy of
principalities that you find in every
single uh culture so the problem is is
also in terms of the dismissive the
dismissive tone is like it's like if I'm
trying to bridge a way to help you
understand in a in a in a more
reasonable fashion something which
exists in every culture
you know for has existed in every
culture for thousands of years it's it
seems like this is a that should not
unless you want to dismiss those
cultures completely as being stupid for
thousands of years
despite let's say also having
civilizations which will probably last
longer than ours yes no it's like I
don't know I think that it's it's
probably a better a better uh effort
rather to help to try to help us
understand what they were doing if we
can help people in our terms today help
them help us understand at least a
little bit what they were doing it seems
like that's something that we that is
worth the effort
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so hello everybody uh there are no
introductions needed uh as you can see
I'm here with uh my friend John dravaki
who we've been having conversations now
for several years uh this growing
conversation and uh John is working on a
a new video series called after Socrates
and so I invited him here to talk about
it kind of give us a sense of what it is
he's trying to do and of course for
certain we will wander into all kinds of
interesting subjects at the same time so
John thanks for coming uh it's a great
pleasure uh to be here Jonathan I've uh
we I don't think we have we talked since
Thunder Bay I don't think I don't think
so like a few emails and everything and
so people we're planning another
conference with people by the way just
to say it's going to be in California
probably I think in the spring at some
point we haven't I don't think we we the
dates are clear yet but it's coming so
that that's great so John tell us a bit
about what this prod this new project of
yours is so this this is a project uh
intended to be at the scale of Awakening
for the meaning crisis but it'll only be
25 episodes not 50.
um and so it's you know and really
up the production value
um and first I'll talk a little bit
about the format and then I'll talk more
a little bit about the content I'm
trying to do a lot with the format
really explore and experiment with it so
like Awakening from the meaning crisis
they'll be a lecture series a continual
argument that builds
but in addition there'll be I I give
points to ponder and my intent is that
people will ponder that individually but
also perhaps that will help discussion
groups
um before discussion groups forming and
then third for almost every episode not
every single episode but I give a
practice that people can engage in a
meditative practice a contemplative
practice it's a dialogical practice and
it builds in order to give people a
participatory and perspectival sense of
what's being talked about
um in the in the lecture so there there
are these three things running and then
I also break from it just being me
um and about halfway through
episodes 10 A and B
um it's me with Christopher Master
Pietro guy send stock and Taylor Barrett
and then and we take everybody through
like we do a demonstration and an
enactment of you know of meditation uh
contemplation some of the stuff I did at
Thunder Bay and Beyond
um and so there's that
um and then also there's the series
within the series which is I break from
the monologue and Christopher Master
Pietro and I do
um Socrates and kirkegaard and the and
the deep and important relationship
between Socrates and kirkegaard and then
that of course gives us a venue in which
we can talk about the relationship
between the socratic project and the
Christian project and of course
kirkegaard wrestled with that very
profoundly and that's been done
dialogically
um and so uh really trying uh to uh play
with this medium and open it up and
really exemplify new possibilities for
how it can afford people entering into
deep discussion entering into a colleges
of practices uh getting involved with
other people Etc so that's that's the
big sort of difference in the format I'm
very very
um
very very happy because I had an amazing
crew uh uh Chris altorf and his brother
Casey and some other people are just
doing amazing work on that so it'll look
a lot better it'll sound a lot better
and it won't just be me in a room with a
white board
um it it's a lot I'm trying to as much
as possible exemplify what I'm talking
about in the series but maybe I'll pause
there in case so is there is there a
public during the during the filming
like do you have people there with you
no we didn't do that but I'm hoping that
like I said that there'll be that people
will uh get engaged with it with other
people I'm really trying to exemplify
that encourage that
um and give people a chance to bring I
mean I'm trying to exemplify even in the
discussion with Chris right trying to
like you and I have been doing trying to
bridge between these worlds that have
typically been isolated even though we
have tremendous resources for trying to
bridge between them and again trying to
do that in a dialogical fashion Chris is
an Ardent uh I don't know what to call
it the follower of kricker guard and you
know Chris you know how eloquent yeah I
had a discussion with him that was going
to probably be up by the time this one
goes up so yeah excellent that would be
great
so that that's the that's the the format
of it the content is after Socrates in a
bunch of ways I'm trying to I'm after
Socrates in the sense of pursuing him
and trying to understand him and all the
people have who have tried to pursue him
and understand him and then there's
after Socrates in the sense of well who
are these people that came after
Socrates and so I'm trying to trace out
the whole tradition the socratic
tradition all the way through up to its
culmination in
um people like aragina and kuza I picked
them for specific reasons I know you why
isn't maximus in there or something like
that but here's my reason for me
two of the main themes
uh are uh this interconnected of that
reality is inherently dialectical in the
platonic sense and aragina for me is
really really clear on that
um and then Nicholas of kuza is the
corresponding uh learn learned ignorance
and learned ignorance I think is the
culmination of socrata of the socratic
proposal that the wise person is the one
who ultimately knows what they do not
know but of course taken through this
whole huge uh neoplatonic and then
eventually Christian neoplatonic
tradition and what I'm trying to do is
help people I'm not claiming that this
is what was going on in Socrates or the
platonic dialogues although I'll make a
lot of arguments around it but I'm
trying to reverse engineer from this
entire entire tradition what is right
this whole Socratic platonic neoplatonic
practice of dialectic into dialogues
what I'm trying to reverse engineer it
and make it plausible make it powerful
make it practicable for people
that's that's the content yeah so there
so definitely it's not like because the
first series you did was more like kind
of The History of Thought through the
lens uh and also explaining the the the
Notions of relevance and all these kind
of Concepts that you play with so here
you're really dealing with basically
taking someone by the hand and kind of
saying like Okay so now let's do do this
like this yeah exactly exactly uh now
let's do this what would it be like to
take this up as a way of life
um and and to very responsibly put that
way of life into deep conversation with
other ways of life uh so you know I
talked at the beginning about you know
Socrates and Jesus and I I believe this
is done very respectfully uh one of the
people Casey is a Christian and so he
said so I was right right and you know
because they're both they both talk
about being midwives helping give give
birth and I you know and they're and
there are Christians who have talked
about that and I said so I want to pick
up on that and then that's why it leads
into you know what are the what's the
Deep interconnections uh between the
socratic way and the Christian way first
in that you know culmination in aragina
and Nicholas at kuza but also in this
deep dialogue that I'm having with with
Chris about Socrates and kirkegaard and
how kirkegaard has really I think I
really recommend people uh to really
like the philosophical fragments where
he's really wrestling about uh how did
Chris put it he's a follower of Jesus
but Socrates is his teacher right uh and
so there's this real because you know he
wrote his PhD thesis on Socrates and
things like that right so so I'm really
wanting to help
explicate
exemplify the socratic way and I'll I'll
name that for that whole tradition
introductory and then how it's also
bound up with the Christian way how it's
bound up with the cultivation of wisdom
and I will I do bring some cogs eye in
like how could you not right I bring it
in along the way there's stuff around
relevance realization stuff that's come
up
um about you know in the discussions
I've had with you and with Paul uh the
discussions I had with the Buddhist
monks when I was at uh Maple
um and things like that so
um yeah it it represents
really trying to turn this from
theorizing into
proposing how one could enter into a way
of life
so do you think that let's say because
you talk about how for you this this
process culminates in in Regina and
Nicholas bakusa do you think that in the
west people went away from what Socrates
had brought yeah yeah I think so and
this comes out at the very beginning of
the series when I talk about
sort of a a what's called new way and
sometimes people a third way sometimes
people also say third wave uh platonism
which is this whole new recent
scholarship around Plato
um that's really taken off uh important
figures like Gonzalez uh Drew Highland
Kirkland uh ruchik a whole bunch of
important Scholars who are really
arguing
um that and this follows in some way
um from earlier points uh
ah
well I won't go into that but it it it's
because that's just another yeah
that what we we treated the the
dialogical nature of Plato's philosophy
as ornamental
actually essential
and Central
um and and and crucially important and
of course this ties in with my argument
that the propositional the procedural
the spectacle of the participatory are
all bound up together and that dialectic
into Dia logos
um
is
um Central to that and I think we
we've only recently in the last 20 or 30
years has this become the new way of
really understanding Plato and
correspondingly understanding Socrates
because you can't pull them apart right
yeah uh that I think affords us a
profound recovery of what was really
going on in that tradition and uh for
people who are even like yourself who
are a Christian right why why were
Christians so deeply attracted to this
way why did it matter so much to them
why did they feel that they needed to
enter into deep dialogue with it if you
go into most
well so let's change that if you went
into the philosophy classes I went into
about Plato and Socrates you would you
wouldn't have any clue as to why do any
why does anybody care about this other
than some arcade arguments about whether
or not there are universals and stuff
like that and so very much trying to
bring this back
um and that's also part of a larger
project which is this thing I've been
talking about and I mentioned to you how
I think Neil platonism can form like the
courtyard of dialogue it could be the
intellectual Silk Road because of its
capacity to enter into deep reciprocal
reconstruction with Christianity and
Judaism and Islam and Buddhism Etc yeah
and so I mean I'm curious about what you
said in terms of the idea that the
importance of the the dialogue format in
terms of what it is that Plato
was trying to to manifest because you're
right usually the way it's presented to
us and I remember in My Philosophy
classes it's presented to us as if when
it's talking to the protagonist and the
other characters are basically reacting
uh questioning
um
challenging Socrates and then Socrates
is but he's the thread you have to
follow and so you you see it more do you
how do you see that like in terms of how
the dialogue functions in the in how the
dialogical aspect functions in the
dialogues so it's very important to pay
attention to the fact that many of the
dialogues and and in aporia
which really undermines the claim that
what Socrates is doing is laying out an
argument and he's got a conclusion that
he's trying to get us to uh instead
um so for example there'll be a dialogue
on courage and you'll have two figures
two generals I believe
um and they'll they'll both be talking
about courage and and then Socrates will
do his thing he'll ask the questions and
the the definitions don't hold they
don't right and and and and and and and
and if you just follow sort of the
propositions and you don't pay attention
to the drama
it'll come to the conclusion oh well
look it just ends in skepticism Socrates
himself says I don't have a definition
right pay attention to the drama the two
generals first of all they represent
different things and I'll come back to
them in a sec
the two generals say we want our sons to
spend time with you Socrates because it
was the whole question was where should
we send our sons to be educated so
they're more likely to become courageous
so wait wait wait wait
what's going on in this stock if you pay
attention just to the propositions like
skepticism but why if this argument just
leads to a skeptical conclusion to the
general say and this is a moment of
Drama Oh but we want you to be the
person that we send our sons to in order
to learn courage
and you realize oh Socrates is right
he's exemplifying The Virtue and part of
the exemplification is the point that it
has to be exemplified it cannot be
captured by statement but you don't see
that if you don't follow the drama then
you have to pay attention to the
character of these two generals and what
they this one the one General he all he
just I know here's my intuition and Mer
right and Socrates says challenges that
first person intuition the other person
the other person represents sort of
third part Authority well the sophist
taught me this and here's a definition
and here's a definition and Socrates
demolishes that
so the first person and the SEC the
third person are demolished and what's
left is the value of the second person
perspective the dialogical perspective
you have to put the character the drama
together with the argument to see what
is actually happening and what is
actually being conveyed did that make
sense as no that makes sense I mean it's
like because
I think that I've also been very
influenced by the way that I was taught
Plato and so you know it also because of
Plato's kind of hostility and Socrates
is the hostility that existed between
him and the playwright the hostility
between between the way that that Plato
represents the poets and all of these
ideas the way in which you feel as if
the the the
um dramatic aspect of the of the
dialogues would be accidental but I mean
I I it would make I think you're forcing
me to rethink
to rethink the dialogues myself because
because what you're describing makes a
lot of sense like it makes a lot of
sense in terms of
of how it is that how it is that
it can also help us explain sometimes
why Plato why Socrates does certain
things which are sometimes rather
mysterious like in terms of of logic oh
yeah yes yes exactly uh because he's
often doing something for a pedagogical
purpose than for a strictly logical
connection to be made and and like we
read I got the great pleasure to talk to
him and we're going to talk again DC
Schindler you know his book uh the
Plato's critique of impure reason and he
just lays out like even the structure of
the Republic how Socrates goes down to
Paris and then like like he's he's
actually exemplifying going into the
cave right and then coming out of the
cave like there's all of this is going
on
then you have to pay attention because
why is why why is Plato putting in that
structure because Plato's trying to
emphasize that the ascent and the return
are both important to understand what
Socrates and what wisdom are about we
have tended to only emphasize the ascent
but socrates's return into the depths of
the cave is as important to
understanding the socratic project and
so again you have to pay attention to
the structure uh and I I I think it it I
I agree it's it's
it helps to explain so many things like
there's dialogues in which Socrates is
the one that's getting sort of beaten up
with the parmenities famous yeah yeah
yeah right right and they're and there
are and there are dialogues when
Socrates withdraws or he's not even
present like the later dialogues because
Plato is he keeps trying to dramatize
and write something and he's trying to
and in the letter right you know the
seventh letter uh Plato talks about how
he he gave the world a more beautiful
Socrates right uh and so you have to
like there's something going on there
above and beyond this is just you know a
stage so that Plato's mouthpiece
Socrates can utter propositions about
some theory that Plato has which uh I I
agree with many of the current
scholarship Pluto doesn't have a theory
of the forms the forms don't play that
role in his theory
um they they have a much different
function and that's related to all this
dialogical stuff we're talking about but
I'm talking too much no no no this is
this is great so I mean what do you what
are you hoping what are you hoping to
like what are you going where are you
going for what are you hoping to
accomplish with with this
well I'm hope I I'm hoping that
um
well some things have already happened
some people are uh even before this
because of some of the interviews I've
been having and discussions they're
going back and rereading Plato and
getting stuff out of it that they didn't
get before and I think that's important
um because I agree with Arthur verse
Lewis
what because we often don't read we
often don't read the the actual
dialogues we read you know
regurgitations of them like we because
we read read in secondary sources I had
a similar experience I read the feedra
recently because I because I was talking
about the problem with pharmacon and you
know I was in Judah and so I went back
to read feedre and and now that even
what you said just lit so many things
for me because there's some gestures
that Socrates poses like he covers his
face at some point because he's too
embarrassed to say certain things you
know because you know it's like it's
like this weird relation of Seduction
you're not sure exactly what's going on
in terms of Socrates and fidra uh and so
so you realize that the gestures he's
posing the the actual physical the way
that he's described is acting as part of
what he's trying to bring out in the
problem of this outside world that he's
in you know crossing the river going
outside the city and now what is that
space you know yes yes and
you get you get the emphasis this is you
know this goes way back to Gonzalez's
book
um dialectic and dialogue and Plato
which is one of the first books of the
Third Way arguing that Plato is really
trying to point us towards
non-propositional knowledge uh
non-propositional knowing you can see
why I would find that important and how
Central that is for uh actually
enabling and affording profound
transformation and that the the socratic
cultivation of the self is a properly
aspirational cultivation of the self and
therefore it is committed to profound
transformation so all those things that
Socrates are doing that are so weird
right if you go back and re-read them
um they they make they make they make a
lot more they make a lot more sense
which is what good exeges to do
If people could read in this new way
that's important yeah if they're if they
would
I agree with Arthur versus Lewis that I
think neoplatonism is kind of like the
spiritual grammar of the West
um you and I sort of agree and sort of
disagree on that and that's that's fine
uh but
um I think the degree to which people
are
and I don't mean this in an insulting
way but to read which people are
ignorant of it and agree to which people
only know of it as a set of propositions
about weird things that people used to
think I think is the degree to which
people are cut off from this very
valuable uh well way of life and I want
people to be I want to be able to afford
people
uh returning to this way of life and I
as I keep emphasizing that returning to
that way of life in a dialogical fashion
which means that way of life has to be
put into dialogue with other important
ways of life and that's what is needed
right now well that's my proposal at
least yeah I what I love about what
you're saying in terms of our constant
discussion is that that there is a sense
in which you seem to be proposing that
the the
it's a
the vision that Plato presents or the
even the vision that that Socrates
presents you know through through Plato
is bound in the drama like it's a story
it's really that which is carrying let's
say this is preventing the the ideas
from being only propositional which is
bringing them into into this engaged
experience yes and again I don't deny
the importance
um but I would say that the point of the
narrative given my previous point is to
take us to what is beyond uh the
narrative the non-propositional the
non-narrative in some fashion
um the relationship to the good or to
the one
um and and I think that's important
um I'm I'm all I'm because because of
you
I'm in and I'm grateful for this I mean
and these videos are going to be
released soon I I mean I I'm gonna have
two videos but I've had discussions
Beyond this with um with Bishop Maximus
from uh Patagonia who's an Eastern
Orthodox uh bishop and also but also
philosopher he teaches in the Seminary
and we've been having an ongoing
discussion about this uh he has a
proposal about what he called and he's
very strict about this the
Transfiguration of neoplatonism within
Christianity yeah and how that differs
from how it was taken up in the West in
scholasticism I think that's that's very
very cool and so I don't want to deny
what yes uh but but I but I want to say
that and Plato uses Mythos and this is
something people forget like and and he
uses symbols in your sense of the word
The Divided line is not an Al is
something more like the sun isn't just
an allegory we literally do depend on
the size right right right right uh and
so they're they're like you have to take
all of these things you have to take the
symbols The Narrative and the argument
and also the character that's being put
like all of this has to be taken in and
I would argue
because what Plato's trying to do is I
mean he's clearly trying to get us
he's trying to activate and integrate
and make it present to us the
non-propositional and how important and
Central it is
and how much it affords a way of
transformation and that's why he uses
all of these things because he's trying
to simultaneously
trigger the the propositional the
procedural the perspective on the
participatory and integrate them and
then Orient them towards something
yeah that's I mean I I think what you're
saying I mean like I have to stop
thinking because because it's really I'm
really it's like I'm going through what
I know like I haven't read all the
dialogue but like the dialogue that I
have read I'm kind of going through them
and I'm seeing uh and also because there
are some elements like you said there's
some elements of the dialogue which gets
pulled out sometimes and shown as being
exemplary of what Plato thought but then
you find contradiction if you if you see
it there yes right so right in the in
the um Symposium you get this silly myth
right the silly myth of the with the
round people like there's yeah yeah
logos if you want to admit and get this
like really silly myth of these circuit
round people and like the two opposites
that joined together which is weird
because the modern people are not
Sometimes using that as a actual like
myth of ancient people believe but when
you read it in the text it's clear that
this is they're making fun of they're
making fun of this uh and so I've I've
read I remember having professors
telling me like this is Plato mocking
Mythos and how Mythos isn't part of of
his thought but then when you go into
when you see some of the images you use
like the image of the Chariot for
example with the two horses like there's
these images that he uses that are that
are right out of like my symbolic
Playbook right they they just it
perfectly fits into this idea of
and and even there I think Plato's
critique of Aristophanes
um
is very is nuanced I don't think it's
mockery I think he also thinks there's
something right about this idea of love
finding something that it right
um right to that is like that is lacking
in us
um and that we can't give to ourselves
but we nevertheless need for our core
self like like there's stuff in there
because Socrates actually says that he
thinks that well it's sort of Plato
seems to indicate that Socrates
Aristophanes speech is the best one
until Socrates speaks right yeah yeah
you're right because all the other ones
are like sort of medical reductionism
and just self self-indulgence but
Aristophanes is so I agree there's a
critique there I think it's more subtle
than marketing yeah okay I think I think
it's like
um again it's like what's going on there
um and and so it's it I think it's Plato
in in that sense sort of being better
than Aristophanes he's he's not simply
like Aristophanes does in the clouds
he's not simply mocking uh well you know
but he's doing something a little bit
more nuanced and and sophisticated
around that yeah you're probably right
maybe it's because I want him to be
marking her stuff and he's so I agree to
tell you that way even more but I mean
but but think about it I mean there's
even something in your work a lot about
the left and the right hand and the
master feminine that you know I get it
it's it's presented in a comical fashion
he's Aristophanes yeah but there's
something in that myth that myth is also
pushing on those yeah the idea of the
androgynous being yeah for sure like I
tend to see the the creation of Adam and
Eve as being something like like when it
says that it took Eve from Adam's side I
tend to think of it like
cut in half like this idea of separating
and being into two opposites that's the
way that I tend to see it so yeah
definitely definitely
so I mean I think this is it's exciting
I can't wait to I definitely can't wait
to see it and so are you are you
offering it on YouTube are you going to
be charging for it are you it's going to
be just okay right it's free it's gonna
be free
um and it's gonna start
um January 9th which is a Monday and
it'll be twice a week Mondays and
Thursdays
um and you just go on the YouTube
channel and you can watch it and
um there'll be some more promo videos
and I'm going to release a couple of
videos to try and
try to help people hopefully not in a
heavy-handed fashion like how to how to
take this how to relate uh to after
Socrates
um
um and so I'm very excited about it too
um it's um
it feels
yeah
Awakening was really comprehensive it
was a huge argument
um this one is much more like you said
it's a bunch more about trying to
conduce people into right A pathway uh
and
um I think of one that we've lost and
one that uh I think we need to properly
recover as a way of responding to the
meaning crisis so it goes towards a
criticism and a good criticism
that many people made and you made a
version of it and you know that I've
responded in in the ways that I can to
your criticisms I take them I take them
to heart but you know but at the end but
but what do you do like oh you have a
few practices you know like and that's
no yeah that's exactly right that's a
good criticism there's been two
fundamental responses and they're bound
up in after Socrates one was you and
Paul and you particularly uh you know
this is a very individualistic project
and and so I've yeah no no you're right
and this is why the dialogical it's so
important secondly it's like there's
some practices and all that but you know
there's a way of life and yes right and
that's what I'm trying to bring out
together in after Socrates yes
um the not make this uh uh you know
individualistic in nature
um make it properly dialogical rather
than monological and also not don't just
talk about some practices and some there
but talk about something much more
comprehensive a way of life so that's
that's how I'm trying to respond to some
of the criticisms
yeah and in some ways also I think
what's interesting is I kind of see you
honing in on a neoplatonic like more and
more like pointing in on this new
platonic strain and it also has a it
also I think has the advantage of being
something that already has a coherence
to it right it already is a kind of
coherent body and so on the one hand you
can reinterpret and you can let's say
let's say play with it in ways to
emphasize certain things and not but it
but I think that it definitely will
I think for People for People kind of
coming to it it'll it'll present more as
this as a path like this here's this
coherent path that has existed for about
for thousands of years it's like it's
part of the western path for sure like
there's no way to avoid it this has been
yeah you know this has been something
that has followed through from before
before uh Christianity it influenced
Judaism and then it kind of went into
Christianity and so for even if
Christians sometimes can criticize and
say like no we need the we need the
Christian version let's say it's at
least I think a robust position to hold
like it's a it's a it's a place to stand
where you can really engage in the
discussion and and and you you have all
this Foundation to to pull on and it
doesn't see because a lot of the new
spirituality sometimes people they pull
in from everywhere right yeah which is
which I understand why because in some
ways that's what happens when you're
kind of lost not lost but you're when
things are broken you're like okay you
know pointing like this exactly and so
and so you you you know you go to you go
to a conference and then people will be
you know it's a western person standing
in front of you who probably grew up as
a Christian and and all they're citing
the Buddhist texts and Indian texts and
a native a native perspective and
everything and it's like well okay I get
it but now what like what do I do but
but the platonic tradition it has that
core it has that uh place to stand on it
feels like thank you for saying that the
the uh I mean I'm of course proposing
I'm not proposing Nostalgia I'm
proposing we pick it up and how to move
it forward that's a big part of it too
uh but exactly thank you for saying that
and and secondly that that that
hopefully shifts the focus off me onto
this path
um uh and way of life and I'm trying to
articulate it and I'm trying to I'm
trying to contribute and to propose how
it can be taken forward
um and it can help you deal with the
guru problem like the modern Guru
problem yeah exactly exactly I want to
avoid the guru problem and
um and so that both of those things are
important and after Socrates is an
attempt to address those two like you
say can can can this can this be a
coherent thing that feeds back into
tradition yes
um and then the second one is how do we
how do we get this focused on a way of
life and not sort of just on me and and
the things I'm talking about
um and so it it's it's trying to do both
of those as well that's also why I have
people other than me playing important
parts within the presentation
yeah I mean it will will definitely be
paying attention to that that's I mean
it sounds great I can't wait to see and
then I'll and I can't wait to argue with
you about things that I don't agree with
of course of course and I'll expect you
to yeah and I hope you see
that I'm responding to a lot of
criticisms and you know criticisms given
with effect affection and respect by you
and others in how I'm doing this I I
this is my way of trying to be deeply
responsive and responsible
um to a lot of those points and of
course I expect that you and Paul and
other people will like well this is what
I disagree with John and that's fine
um uh but but I do uh there's a there's
a way of responding to criticisms that
is not the attempt to to silence
conversation or prevent disagreement but
that at least people acknowledge Yes you
heard me and you've done something
constructive in response and that's what
I'm trying to do that's great yeah
that's wonderful and So based on what on
that I think that one of the things that
I've appreciated that's been going that
I've seen happen recently is you know
there I there has been there was this
contention it didn't seem contentious
when we were talking about it when we
had this discussion a while ago with
Rebel wisdom and I brought up the idea
that the way that you talk about
transpersonal agency in seems to connect
very closely to the ancient way that
people talked about yeah about Spiritual
Beings and how Spiritual Beings affect
us and everything and it seems like
there was an interesting possibility
creating the bridge and that I think
since I've been speaking on YouTube it's
the thing that I that has brought about
on me the most criticism and it's also
because it probably until then I didn't
touch
like I was Far Enough from from let's
say touching the modern psychological
apparatus or the modern way in which we
understand things so that people either
didn't know what I was talking about or
didn't see how it was going to affect
like their world view didn't challenge
them yeah and challenge the world view
exactly and so I've appreciated I I've
seen you let's say being forced to like
defend just even talking to me
in terms of this question uh so so I
wanted to express that thanks as well
because I really appreciate it I know
that in some ways probably
it's it's still an exploratory
discussion yeah I know that that uh
there are several questions that still
need to be let's say
that have to be dealt with in terms of
understanding how these things Bridge or
not or how they connect but uh but I
appreciate the fact that that you
defended me let's say or you tried to
defend my position even though you don't
necessarily even hold my position I yeah
I I
well first of all the defense of the
proposal is because I think there's
there is Parts I deeply agree with we do
disagree on some points but there's
Parts I deeply do agree with and uh and
even the parts I I disagree with I think
it is a proposal that should be taken
seriously
um and and yeah I yeah there was a
couple of videos and I also did uh I did
a stupid thing I tried to make an
argument on Twitter defending you uh
yeah yeah never do that yeah I think so
well I have to say there was a lot of
positive uptake of that argument uh and
so yeah there were sort of three venues
in which uh I tried like because they
were trying to make you sound like an
idiot and I I am
well I'm I'm first of all I'm really
convinced you're not an idiot and
secondly uh you again I just I also
deeply dislike that strategy uh that
that I I mean I get it a lot too uh it's
usually along the lines of John is just
blah blah blah blah therefore I can
dismiss him it's a dismissive strategy
rather than an engagement strategy and I
think there's no defense at all for
dismissive strategies I think if you do
this just a strategy you deserve to be
dismissed seriously
um and so that also sort of got me a
little bit like ah first of all
Jonathan's not an idiot uh he he enters
in good faith and he brings a lot of
intelligence I I try to bold out what I
thought the argument was at least how I
was taking it right and then and then
it's like don't be dismissive engage or
shut up right I'm sorry I'm just like
like please right we we we do not need
uh we like that that that that
dismissive at I don't have to think
about you because here's my you know
you've put in you know two decades of
work and I can dismiss it by this it's a
three premise there's three sentence
response I like like come on like please
right enter in like ask questions make
criticisms but don't but do it in an
Engaged fashion don't try to be
dismissive and what I was hearing was an
attempt to dismiss you which is also
what what that irks me yeah and so and
so I I've been thinking a lot about
because I you know I I listen like I
listen to the to the the
poking and people saying like what what
is going on like how does he try to
connect how does he able to connect
these things together I've been thinking
a lot about the idea of transpersonal
agency in terms of
again trying to bridge the traditional
categories like the angiology of the
ancient world and the even just the
hierarchy of gods or the hierarchy of
principality that you find in every
single uh culture so the problem is is
also in terms of the dismissive the
dismissive tone is like it's like if I'm
trying to bridge a way to help you
understand in a in a in a more
reasonable fashion something which
exists in every culture
you know for has existed in every
culture for thousands of years it seems
like this is a that should not unless
you want to dismiss those cultures
completely as being stupid for thousands
of years
despite let's say also having
civilizations which will probably last
longer than ours yes no it's like I
don't know I think that it's it's
probably a better a better uh effort
rather to help to try to help us
understand what they were doing if we
can help people in our terms today help
them help us understand at least a
little bit what they were doing they
seems like that's something that we that
is worth the effort I I totally agree
and I think you're right I think that
part of this is right uh
exactly uh sort of the Enlightenment
Mythos of uh of the priority of of the
of the present and the future and the
future the the past is something we
leave behind because it was bound in
Superstition
Etc I think it's completely legitimate
for us with knowledge that we have that
people in the past didn't have to make
criticisms but I think it's also
important to realize that we as you said
are also locked into ways of seeing that
might you know might might be open to
Serious education by paying attention to
what other cultures at other times have
said even our own culture in previous
historical epochs this is part of what I
was saying earlier about
like we we had a we hadn't we had a way
of reading Plato that was largely so
that we could put Plato behind us so
that we could get to Descartes this is
like this introduction to philosophy
here's Plano here's some Aristotle
see why this doesn't work Descartes
right and then Descartes can't and there
we and and boost right and because all
that really matters are these core
epistemological problems it's like well
maybe not maybe that's actually the
wrong way of framing the whole problem
of you know right and so I think that
that that that there's a lot of
trying to dismiss you
um because you you are doing exactly
what you're talking about you're talking
you're trying to say maybe there's
something we can learn from these people
and their mythological World Views I
happen to agree with that
um I don't happen to agree with
everything you say about it but I happen
to agree with that part of it yeah um
and and I I'm not quite and I even and I
even when I made the argument I said
like putting aside the religious thing
durkheim makes similar arguments yeah
and your claim is like Central to
anthropology and sociology I'm not
saying durkheim is right but people
don't go oh stupid durkheim who like no
no he's a pivotal figure like like like
yeah I think the difference between
between let's say what I am trying to
propose and what durkheim would have
been proposing is that I am proposing a
type of agency which is real coming from
above and so it's not just that humans
put things as as you know Elevate things
as being let's say totems you know or or
characteristics that they that they
create their identity around which is
which seems to be more a bit what
durkheim was proposing rather that
there's also what there's definitely a
top-down relationship that that identity
then binds and that there is a form of
agency which binds coming back down on
the group which is which is bound by it
okay so two things to say about that
first of all that second part I think
there's a cognitive scientific argument
to be made about that about distributed
cognition and collective intelligence
top-down causation and you know that you
and I have talked about that the other
thing is I think I think you should be a
little bit more charitable to durkheim I
think durkheim he doesn't have that
developed but he definitely has the idea
of the super organic and and and and you
know and and uh and that that represents
or has an impact on people it's I think
it's it's preliminary in durkheim but I
think there's a legitimate opening even
within durkheim for talk talking about
right collective intelligence
distributed cognition and its top-down
effect on an individual participants
which only strengthens the argument to
my mind yeah yeah yeah and so and I've
been thinking a little bit about the
question of independent existence
because I know that's one of the things
that came up in the discussion which is
that do these angels exist without
humans right do these transpersonal
agencies without humans and I tend like
I always have the same approach like my
I really believe in a fractal structure
of reality and so if I want to test
something up here I'd test it down here
at my level and I and I I use that as an
analogy to help me transpose the problem
and so the question happened the same
question can be asked about me the
question is do I exist without my body
and the answer is it's a ridiculous
question it's actually not a question
like what are you asking you know that
at least in the Christian position like
Saint Gregor Nissa says clearly that
humans begin to the Human begin to exist
in their bodies they don't pre-exist in
some temporal way you could say that
they exist in the mind of God from all
eternity if you wanted to say something
like that or they exist in the totality
of all things like there are ways to
formulate like a kind of pre-existence
but it's not uh it's not a pre-existence
in time and so the idea of understanding
uh transpersonal agencies seems to be
the same so there's a manner in which we
can say
it pre-exists just like you could say
about you to a certain in certain manner
like just follow me through this
argument
right that you pre-exist your body and
the reason why you could say something
like you pre-exist your body is because
the elements of your body are changing
and so like the the actual like
chemicals in your body and the parts
like they're not the same that you had
when you were born right they they
they've moved they it's like it's a it's
a what is it the ship of Theseus problem
right yes yes very much and so you you
you pre-exist your body in that sense
and so you could also understand that
transpersonal agency pre-exists the
bodies in that sense that is a
basketball team that has a coherent
agency acting on it that acts as a body
the players can change
right that and the even the management
can change there's a certain amount of
of variability possible in the body
but the agency can remain the same
despite the change of the body there's a
limit there's a limit at some point if
you shatter the the manifestation too
much like if you shatter the body too
much and at some point it at some point
it separates and then then there's no
then there's no being like there's no
being anymore but but so I think that if
we see it that way then we we can both
understand the reason why we talk about
Angelic pre-existence but also
understand that Angels don't exist
without their subtle bodies either like
they exist in the world through the
effects that they have and so that you
know the angel of Charity doesn't exist
without charity like there has to be
acts of Charity in the world where the
angel of Charity to exist like the let's
say the the Angelic the virtues which
are one of the hierarchy of angels are
the easiest to understand in that sense
it's like there is no Angel of Hope
without hope there has to be hope there
has to be a body of Hope for the Angel
of Hope to exist
okay this first of all this is
tremendously helpful
um I I let me let me try and say
something similar and I um
so we talked about you know you know
non-reducibility the um you can't reduce
uh you I can't reduce you to your
chemical structures because you are
instantiated in different chemicals that
and your body isn't the same even
physical body it was when you were 25
and all that sort of ship of uh Theseus
kind of thing I mean same thing with a
computer program I can put this computer
program in this computer or that
computer or that computer what makes it
the same program now can it be free of
any computer that's weird but can you
reduce it to any one computer no and in
that sense it it you know it pre-exists
being in that computer because it's in
this computer
Etc and then secondly like you said that
it it these things can't exist
um
independently of their manifestations
and and I think
let me let I'll try and phrase this as a
question there's a connection that
coming up we got into a point in our
discussion where I propose to you that
these higher things might not have
Consciousness or self-consciousness and
and you were very gracious about that
you said you know there there might be
something in that because the angels are
actually really weird in a lot of
Mythology and they they like the angel
of death is that like is that a
self-conscious being and stuff like that
like and and I thought that was also
very helpful uh because I think there's
a lot of questions that are being mixed
up together here and so are these things
self-conscious
um do they exist before us independently
from us self-consciously and I think
what you're saying and I'm not saying we
completely agree but you're saying those
questions are kind of picking up on the
wrong Parts like you're emphasizing
aspects of the mythology that are are
not actually the parts that should be
emphasized
um uh so
I I I I I guess what I'm asking is does
that sound like I'm getting you fairly I
think so I think so I think I do think
that I'm definitely
I'm far more open to the idea of
Consciousness transpersonal
Consciousness because I I really don't
see any reason apart from that I can't
experience it that they're that they're
that Consciousness and
self-consciousness should should that
human beings should be the crown of of
Consciousness like I don't necessarily
see that that's necessary in any way
like because I see Consciousness scaling
you know up to me up to a human I I have
like like I said just the the reason why
I I hesitate is because I can't
experience the consciousness of a
transpersonal being like I I don't have
access to it I don't I don't know like I
don't even know what that would be like
what type of Consciousness would it be
but I definitely don't exclude it
because
uh because I yeah because there's
something it's interesting though
there's something about agency and
Consciousness which I find fascinating
in some of the secularist type of
argument which is that there seems to be
a desire to make like the human person
very very special in some ways because
like the the offense that I feel like
this almost this this sense of like that
all of a sudden you know you're touching
this deep taboo when I say why wouldn't
there be transpersonal Consciousness
like why does it bother you that that
would be a a reality if you notice the
pattern of agency acting on groups of
humans why does it bother you that there
would be Consciousness uh as even and
materialists like even as a naturalist
why would the human being be the summit
of all things like I I that that's also
something that I that I've been
wondering about in terms yeah let me
help you on that point and then all well
first of all it's like notice how
important Consciousness and
self-consciousness is for agency and for
attribution and you're trying to put
that into a worldview that often tries
to claim that Consciousness and
self-consciousness are reducible at the
phenomenal of knowing like
that that's a big tension that's a huge
tension in in that sort of position it's
like then you're saying that there
really is something ontologically real
and important about Consciousness and
self-consciousness and that doesn't fit
in well with any kind of reductive
materialism so first of all I I think
you're arguing a big strength in there
secondly
um I this has to go and I don't want to
repeat our conversation right I I never
said in principle that it wasn't
possible I just said I think I do I do
kind of something like you do I look at
what are what are the con conditions
that seem to track here with
Consciousness about connectivity and
recursivity and stuff that really
exemplified in the nervous system do we
have good evidence that that's possible
is it logically possible yes do we have
any physical means of instantiating that
right now I don't think so so I tend to
say I think we have clear evidence for
intelligence I think that not in
principle but in practice right now I
don't see how it can be yeah so you
would say intelligence and agency but
not not Consciousness but so here's my
full thing we're not self-consciousness
right intelligence and agency not
Consciousness or self-consciousness but
not in principle impossible only in fact
not the case that's a different thing
yeah yeah yeah
so like so sorry because we are going to
kind of could jump back into our
conversation but but like so if so when
it's let's say a city uh defends itself
against parasites like when a city
defends itself against criminals
and so you you can't see that there's a
form of of consciousness of its state
like it there's a form of consciousness
of its borders and how it's well no
because I think you're not crumbling and
how it's How It's let's say holding
together or functioning smoothly until
it sends out it sends out like some kind
of but you bodies do that without
Consciousness I understand I understand
that's what I think I can say your
immune system is fantastically
intelligent at that and yet I have no
reason or evidence that it's conscious
let alone self-conscious yeah but it
happens through like it will happen
through meaningful orders especially in
that case
it'll be like a law there'll be like a
statement there'll be like a general
telling the military to go and do these
things like there'll be this
there'll be like a a
at least at the level of the humans will
be Consciousness going down like towards
the action they would agree but even
that is not all the way down because
your Consciousness doesn't permeate down
to the chemical interactions that are
making your body move no for sure not no
for sure so I like I I see Consciousness
attenuating at both ends okay that way
right
all right so I I like I said I I mean I
definitely hold the traditional I hold
the traditional kind of Christian
position in some ways so I I tend to but
I understand why we need to definitely
to do I need to think about it more and
we need to do more work in terms of
trying to find ways to to formulate the
analogies so so we can see how far we
can go with this question and and and
and I also again want to say you know
the three papers that I published with
Dan Chaffee about you know the
scientists moving The Rovers around in
Mars and all of this uh two things like
this is this is this idea about
Collective agency collective
intelligence distributed cognition we
agency this is Cutting Edge stuff so
this is innovative and important and
secondly and and this is not
inconsequential you know and I've picked
up on this and some of the talks I gave
it like the talk I gave at Cambridge
like there was a there was a
spirituality that naturally sort of
emerged within the scientists this weird
thing about how they like they really
almost sympathize aesthetically
magically identified with the Rover and
they did these rituals where they would
embody the Rover or they would
anthropomize the Rover and personalize
it and and this was not just ornamental
this was crucial to them being able to
do the work like that's also an
important point to be made and I make it
uh like again it's not the same as what
you're claiming but it's also but it it
also means that you're not like
saying something completely like you
know out of the blue yeah well for sure
in the case that you're talking about it
could definitely help you understand
totemization practices like different
types of of practices tribal practices
of identification with with Spirit
Animals you know like this idea of
certain characteristics that that we
recognize as as identifying us and then
binding us but then also manifesting in
the way we act and so there's you could
you could see how that would function to
cohere a group and get them to act
coherently against their enemies in the
world they together with other tribes
like they would do that you can
understand that with your Mars Rover
experiment definitely right and it also
it points to the ritual and the imaginal
like that that's not just sort of a
belief system they're enacting it and
they're and they're and they're drawing
on the photographs and they're doing all
this stuff that's imaginable
in order to afford them actually being
able to be present isn't on Mars to get
that actual perspectival knowing like it
it's so again I agree with everything
you said about and and vertese does use
the word totem by the way that the Rover
became a totem for them but I want you
to understand that it's simultaneously
like a social process but also it it
interpenetrates deeply into cognitive
accordance it actually enables people to
do to see and to do the work they need
to do yeah it's not so yeah it's not
just like you said it actually makes the
it makes it easier for them to to exist
this way like it's not just that they're
not just they're not just telling
themselves I mean like let's say like
it's not just a team rattling themselves
up you know with their mascot and with
their things there's more of a kind of
an actual embodiment of the Rover
through practices that that make it that
what they're trying to do is more
effective yep exactly exactly exactly
and and that by the way then feeds back
that see the spirituality and the
affordance of uh of agency feedback into
the point we're making before about
top-down effects actually making a
difference in the cognition and the
sense making of the individuals hmm
all right yeah that makes a lot of sense
and and definitely definitely it is it
is more food for thought and and I know
that we're going to continue this
conversation forever as long as we as
long as we still breathe so I would want
to say that this stuff and actually some
of the more recent stuff I've done on
the imaginal and the ritual also gets
developed and articulated
um in after Socrates yeah and I think
that's great I also think that there's a
their
I mean I'm gonna say this I might get in
trouble for this but you know the notion
of the imaginal has been controversial
in in Orthodox circles because of the
ascetic practice of hezekism and ezicasm
the the because the the um these because
what the the monk or what the
practitioner is trying to do is to
attain Unity Full Union with God there's
a sense in which the imaginal space
becomes a dangerous face like it's a yes
it's an intermediary like it's like the
spirits of the air right this
intermediary space that has to be that
has to be crossed in order to reach the
highest person so the tendency is to say
ignore the images ignore the ignore the
imagination part so that you can reach
silence and beauty and light right so
basically going all the way up into the
highest fear but I think that a lot of
work that that uh certain people that I
know have been doing or father and
justiniano some of my work and other
people's work as well by using
iconography like what we did in Thunder
Bay right using iconography as the
support to show that this imaginal space
also has a positive as a positive
manifestation and it's like the church
full of all these paintings and drawings
and images like it really is and the way
that it's structured and how it does
represent a cosmic image and all of this
I think has been has been a good bridge
to help people understand that that the
the there is room in Christianity for
this notion of a positive vision of this
intermediary world and and the imaginal
space and we need it because without it
I think that we're I think that we're
very like Christians are very vulnerable
without developing a robust vision of
this intermediary space
I totally agree and I think
um the imaginal is I mean it's just
it's like what we said about narrative
um or right it it it's bound up with uh
human cognition an important way I I
would propose to you that my attitude
towards the narrative is is the same one
you're trying to propose about the
imaginal yes
it's not even my
it is a deep tradition in the Orthodox
in the Orthodox tradition of of uh being
suspicious of of that space so so I kind
of have to deal with it I myself am more
obviously more I mean I I you if you
people know what I'm doing like writing
comic books I mean I'm making all these
things I'm obviously more I have more
room for it but I I also want to
formulate in a way that's respectful to
the tradition because I I do I do
believe that they're that they're good
reasons why Hezekiah had the form that
it did so so maybe then what I what I've
been trying to say
um and again we don't have to pick this
up because we keep going this is another
one of our theories uh by the way before
I forget you released the video I think
was part of your q a where you sort of
said flat out you know John is right
about this about the nomological I want
to now return and say thank you for you
doing that that was gracious and that
was you know part of what we're all
trying to do here together uh but what I
want to say is I think the narrative is
important it is
uh powerful but it is intermediary that
is in a nutshell what I'm trying to say
in a lot of ways yeah I keep getting
casters John doesn't like it's unfair to
attribute to me John doesn't John's a
Critic of the narrative or doesn't think
narrative I've never said that I never
said that I know we gave you from the
meeting crisis that is not my position
and I don't and I it's really straw
personing me to attribute that to
yeah but I think that understanding and
this is the same for the imaginal
question as well is that
you see it in the ascetic I really
sangrer needs his uh life of Moses you
see it clearly in that text you see you
see the Moses goes up the mountain he
removes the garments of skin he removes
the layers he he moves into Divine
Darkness so he basically moves out of
any form any form any any representation
and then but then when he crosses that
space he's given the he's given the
pattern of the Tabernacle and so the
idea is that
this space which is above the narrative
anonymological let's say the
Transcendent or the non-dual or whatever
however you want to name it it's the
source of it right it's the source of
that other space and so so it gives
birth to it and it gives it its proper
its proper form so so it's like so
there's no so you can have both the
aesthetic
understanding of moving into that which
is beyond being but then also
understanding that yeah it's also the
father of being it's also that which
gives being makes it makes it exist I
just you just did to my mind and I don't
think this is dismissive of what you
just did I'm not taking anything away
from Gregory but that's also Socrates
that's a republic
and then they return and if you if you
separate the ascent from the return you
don't understand the ascent I was very
very clear about this yeah uh and DC
Schindler makes a fantastic argument and
that see that's what that that the fact
that there's that convergence there
about exactly that point right
um and that's again that's why that's
why I want to be doing what I'm doing
because then we can oh right let's make
these connections let's draw this out
yeah but that point I think the point
about how the Transcendent gives birth
to the world and how it the world
actually exists out of it I think it's
important today because there's in the
say in the spiritual but not religious
yeah you get that argument right where
it's like well I don't want the religion
I don't want the forms I don't want any
of the practices I just want the top
thing right you know I believe in
non-duality I just want that and
everything else like I don't want and so
there's a there's a
there's a kind of naivete about then how
does then the world exist like how is it
there's more than a night hey there's
more there's more here's here's
Schindler's read on Plato which I think
is profound the absolute that does not
include the relative is not the absolute
right because then it's not if you're
non-duality does not afford
and properly I don't know what to say uh
give birth to I'm trying to like yeah
then you don't unders you haven't
properly understood it you you've
reified it uh like again the the the
ascent and The Descent the emanation and
the emergence you can't you know you and
I've been sort of not arguing about this
is something we're converging on a lot
on and and and and I I think that that
connection you just made is so
appropriate right there's a profound
naivete because it's based on a profound
misunderstanding and misapprehension if
you think the absolute does not include
and I mean deeply Encompass and
interpenetrate the relative then you
have not understood it at all you've
turned it into something like a
totalitarian thing it's a totalizing
rather than an absolute and that and I
think Schindler just knocks that
argument out of the ballpark it just
says look and this is Plato's argument
again and again and again and again
again I think what you said I'm just
deepening it that spiritual bypassing is
not just naivete it's naivete that is
driven by a kind of profound
misunderstanding and misapprehension
yeah and like you said it does it leads
to
it leads to two impulses it leads to a
totalitarian impulse and it leads to a
kind of anarchic impulse yeah both at
the same time like it's like either
anything goes and could just do whatever
because it's like nothing it's all it's
all nothing compared to the absolute or
rather
control like everything has got to be
got to be completely ordered and and and
has to
so so yeah so you're right so they're
they're and in a way like that's the
right that's a that's the right hand of
the left hand right there that's that
that that that optimal grip that that
you talk about you know this idea that
there's this letting go and everything
has a letting go and a grasping to it
yeah yeah that's a neces it's necessary
for the thing to actually exist
I think that's exactly right and I think
you like you you have to be you have to
be constantly opening
to the the the the the the the the
one the absolute the inexhaustible and
you also have to be closing to the
finite right the right uh uh the
suchness and you have to be constantly
doing both or you don't have like you
said you don't have a world yeah you
don't have a world you know and you
don't have the you know you have neither
an intelligible World nor the optimal
grip needed to realize that intelligible
world and that's why spiritual and but I
mean insofar as it is spiritual
bypassing as a psychological category
which it is that's what people are
trying to do right it's kind of a crypto
Gnostic thing of trying to
pretend and I think there is something
pretentious of it that we can somehow be
free from the world like in our
embodiment and and and and
then we don't have a we don't have a a a
a a a a moral uh we don't have moral and
epistemic responsibilities which we do I
mean I've got kids like if the absolute
makes me not treat my kids well well I'm
sorry
like that's not what we're not the
absolute dude something else yeah
um and so I I and I I admit to be fair
to me I did make this explicit criticism
in a way for the meaning crisis I said
any notion of Enlightenment that that
does not have something to tell me about
how to deal with the perennial problems
and cultivate wisdom I'm not interested
in that notion of Enlightenment and why
should you be why should you be other
than you're having some unique
experience that you find really
personally wonderful like how is that
not just self-indulgence or narcissism
I'm sorry that's uh right I I I'm not
saying that people don't have a right to
engage in spiritual exploration or
anything like that I'm not saying that
but when we're talking specifically
about what goes wrong in spiritual
bypassing I think that's what goes wrong
in it
um
this is great John I need to I need to
go I need to go to another appointment
but this is always you we could just
keep going that's the problem just keep
talking forever so everybody so so give
the the last tell people again where the
after Socrates when is it coming where
is it going to be okay so after Socrates
January the 9th there's going to be lots
of promo videos uh there's already been
One released
um it's going to come out on YouTube you
know you'll subscribe to my channel and
you'll get it right away uh it's free
you don't have to pay uh it'll be
released twice a week probably Mondays
and Thursdays twice a week is for sure
we're not quite sure if it's gonna what
that's the Mondays and Thursdays
probably Monday for sure probably
Thursday but definitely twice a week
um January the 9th look for it uh really
strongly recommend try to watch it with
some other people do the discussions
around the points to ponder do the
practices individually and collectively
and then discuss the practices and the
relationship between the practices and
the propositions please
I think I think you'll find it of great
value
all right thanks John and uh you will
definitely be talking soon again if if
not very soon then for sure if we do if
we have this conference in California
that'll that'll be great as well so as
you know I'm always looking forward to
talking to you it's been great thank you
so much Jonathan all right bye-bye bye